the lies are outrageous and on the topic
of this supreme court nominee
we haven't seen anything yet you think
there's no way to attack
a a very qualified well-spoken
judge mother of seven two adopted from
haiti
takes her faith very seriously oh there
is newsweek
publishes a completely false
story completely false 100
bs here's the headline how amy coney
barrett's people of praise group
inspired the handmaid's tale
that's the whole story amy coney barrett
is part of this
charismatic catholic group called people
of praise and that
group inspired the handmaid's tale right
except it didn't so they still have the
story up
they changed the headline obviously
still the story up though correction
this article's headline originally
stated that people of praise inspired
the handmaid's tale
the book's author margaret atwood has
never specifically mentioned the group
as being the inspiration for her work
a new yorker profile of the author from
2017 mentions a newspaper clipping as
part of her research for the book
of a different charismatic catholic
group people of hope
newsreek regrets the error correction
uh yeah no margaret outwould never said
that this was true
and actually then we've got evidence
that it's we know it's not true
but we're going to keep the article up
anyway
that's all you're going to see until
until the election now
which is fine by me because there are
still people in this country believe it
or not
who don't pay a ton of attention to
politics they like just live their lives
they do normal things they go to work
they may occasionally watch a movie or
something
and spend time with your family and
they're gonna see for the next month and
a half however long it is
abject lies the the
public destruction of a very
nice looking smart articulate qualified
mother of seven based on pure lies based
on
nothing that's what they're going to see
and those people who maybe they call
themselves undecided
independent moderate how do you think
that's going to push them
in the presidential election another
great mark for
amy coney barrett mike lee who was also
up for the supreme court is senator mike
lee from utah
i thought he'd be a great candidate for
the court i thought ted cruz would be a
great candidate for the court i've been
pushing for one of those guys great
constitutional lawyers
very clear on their thinking on the law
thought they'd be great on the court
because we would
know where they stand because they've
got this huge public record in politics
and i think it's silly to try to pretend
that uh
judges should never have anything to do
with politics at any point in their
career you know
for for much of this country's history
most of this country's history sometimes
people would go to the courts then
they'd go run for office and maybe
they'd come back to the courts
you had a president who was a chief
justice of the supreme court william
howard taft
you you have all these you had all these
guys and then all of a sudden the last
few decades
no the court you have to be on the court
for life it's like the pope you know you
shouldn't
you're not supposed to be able to resign
the papacy you're supposed to on your
death bed be still talking about
the supreme court i don't think that's
necessary i don't think that's good
and so i was pushing for the senators i
hope you enjoyed that short segment from
the michael knowles show be sure to
check out the full episode linked in the
description
or download the podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
you